So what I've been trying to do with my
videos and,
and,
and I think this is part of the reason
that they've become so popular,
in fact,
I'm certain of it,
is that I've been trying to agitate for
the adoption of that personal
responsibility as an alternative to
political ideology.
It's like get your act together,
have a vision,
straighten out your life.
Say what you think,
you know,
stay away from the ideological idiocies
and simplicity and oversimplifications
and try to put yourself together.
Because I think that I do believe at the
most fundamental level,
and I think this is the remarkable
realization of Western civilization,
is that the well developed individual is
the antidote to the tyranny of society
and biology.
I think that's our great discovery in
the West.
It's not like other cultures haven't had
that idea in nascent form,
but it's been hyper developed in the
west and I think it's right.
And so we abandoned that,
that,
that pathway of divine individuality and
revert to ideological identification of
race or sex.
We're going to tear each other apart.
And I think part of the reason we're
motivated to do that,
Joe,
is because many people don't want to
bear the responsibility of developing
themselves as individuals,
so they'll,
they'll shuffle off the responsibility.
And if that means that you know,
we're dancing in the streets because
everything's on fire,
that'll be just fine.
And that's another thing that's adding
to the terrible danger that we're in
right now.
So.